Emma Watson we loved your performance as
Meg March you did such an amazing job at
portraying the oldest March sister so we
were totally stunned when we found out
that you were the directors second
choice that's right you almost lost the
role to Emma Stone but she had to drop
out of the movie because of scheduling
conflicts funny enough this isn't the
first time you ladies had to compete for
a role after all you were all set to
star as Mia in la-la land until the role
went to Emma Stone when you encountered
scheduling conflicts of your own what
are the odds of that
the newest adaptation of Little Women
just took the big screen and it was
everything we dreamed of and more
everything was exquisite from the cast
to the costumes to the revamped
storyline but fans of the
nineteenth-century novel are quick to
point out that the movie was very
different from the books keep watching
to find out how the movies leading
ladies differ from the novels in the
most ironic way possible thank you on
March 4 your employment and your many
kindnesses but I intend to make my own
way in the world a brand new story line
while Greta Gerwig adaptation of Little
Women
noticeably derives from the original
books by the same name there is one
major difference between these two works
of art mainly the movies timeline has
been played around with and now instead
of focusing on a linear storytelling
groove the movie starts much later in
the timeline than the books do by the
time were introduced to the March
sisters they are all young adults and
not children or teenagers the movie is
pleasantly cut by flashbacks that help
keep the original story the one and only
Amy there are some key differences
between the 1994 and 2019 film
adaptations - mainly Amy Marquez
character isn't split up between two
actors in the 1994 movie the role of Amy
was played by Kirsten Dunst and Samantha
Mathis who played the younger and older
versions of Amy respectively this time
around however Amy will solely be
portrayed by Florence pug I'm not a poet
I'm just a woman if it hadn't been for
Greta Gerwig decision to restructure the
novel's original storyline the film
would have had to cast two versions of
Amy's character a modern take the little
woman books were published over a
century ago and while Louisa May Alcott
was a very full
anger times have changed tremendously
since the novel's first made waves one
notable difference is how the March
sisters stories are told in a much more
ambitious way while Little Women is a
timeless tale filmmaker Greta Gerwig
gave the movie a fresh new spin and it
was extremely well received by fans of
the nineteenth-century novel
joe's point of view another big
difference between the books and the
movie is the narrative the 2019 remake
of Little Women is told through Joe's
point of view and they have souls as
well as just hearts Joe is the second
oldest March sister and she's portrayed
by Saoirse Ronan
what makes this adaptation so special is
how Joe's words make way for her sister
storylines
the narrative condenses the literary and
cinematic universes into one beautiful
frame flashback sequences we've already
mentioned that the 2019 remake recalls
the events of Little Women
by using flashback sequences however we
haven't talked about the movies gorgeous
color palettes
unlike the books which highlight plane
and time appropriate settings the movie
uses color to demonstrate the time gaps
between scenes also the leading ladies
are given different haircuts throughout
the film which isn't something that is
of great significance in all COTS books
some things never change while there are
many differences between the books in
the movie one thing will never change
and that's how Joe refuses to end her
novel the way her publisher recommends
her to in a world that is changing ever
so quickly it's nice to know that some
things never change the new Amy as the
youngest and most superficial of the
March sisters amy was portrayed as a
silly and immature girl who wasn't aware
of her family's financial status but in
the 2019 film adaptation Amy's character
is revamped in the most pleasant way
possible Amy's character is showcased
more deeply and just like Joe amy also
receives a chilling speech the
storylines come together one of the most
satisfying parts of the movie is when
all the storylines finally combine
making way for a very emotional moment
however since the remake focuses on the
inner workings of the March family many
beloved characters from the books didn't
receive nearly as much screen time as
some viewers would have hopes for an
ironic twist we wouldn't go as far as to
call this a major difference between the
movie and the books but it's a ninja
in fact nonetheless release May Alcott's
novel focuses on the lives of four
American sisters ironically none of the
actors who portray that March sisters
are American
emma watson and florence pug are English
whereas Saoirse Ronan is Irish and Eliza
Scanlon hails from Australia funny
enough all for March sisters from the
1994 adaptation of Little Women were
true born Americans if you like fun
facts cool videos and keeping up with
the latest celebrity news subscribe to
the things and click that fell to turn
on notifications this way you can be the
first to comment on our newest videos if
you're watching on your phone or tablet
switch to notifications on your YouTube
settings and that's a wrap on the
biggest Little Women differences between
the movie and the books who's your
favorite March sister tell us in the
comments thanks for watching the things
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see you next time